how do you know can can these are editor
he's been for years
we've met before we met him at the live
show
how many times
and we have conversation
well then there you go
yeah you know like you know you have a
cool face yeah but can like here's the
thing about can he's had to sign like
multiple ndas because he knows
everything that's on the editing room
floor so he knows all of your crazy have
I said [__] up things
[Music]
uh he who's been on TV he's the winner
of America's Best Dance Crew he's an
incredible dancer but you mean it from
Jabbawockeez yeah kind of same show yeah
yeah they're on a different season are
you the one that I did the dance and
yeah oh I know you have a pretended
how do you work
like your [__] yeah yeah what do you
think about Bobby's dance moves like
great really entertaining thank you so
much you think he's like I would say
like he's kind of an original right I
would say so yeah I don't know why
people more people don't do that when
they're on the Dance Floor do something
original they do yeah
sit down there a lot of dancers are yeah
yeah I just don't like the way you're
hunched over yeah yeah it's
uncomfortable it was yeah yeah can you
go closer to the mic or yeah
he's a dancer he's very tired I know
he was very like you know I mean tense
it's because of the type of dancing I do
oh you do robotic yeah
show me something and let's see if can
can
um copy it copy it stand up all right
jellyfish think jellyfish jelly
jellyfish no I'm gonna make up I don't
know what a jellyfish is oh you don't
know what a jellyfish is what you do I
want to just come up my own with my own
moves if you can do it right just check
it out
dude he's got
he's kind of what the [__]
you're a mimic yeah yeah yeah so have I
said things that you've had to edit out
one oh my God that was troublesome
uh to me Troublesome to me yeah no no to
you I like this no I don't care that he
really does that that's the beautiful
thing there's two types of people people
that care and don't care imagine if we
had an editor who was like easily
offended though yeah that would be
insane CAD is a very specific choice for
us because he just is okay with well
he's a jungle Asian said he gets it yeah
you know you guys are the best I love it
how do you feel about Bobby having to
apologize to the entire Vietnamese
Community apologizing for what tell them
what you did yeah years ago years ago
this is probably 15 maybe even longer um
I said um
I said chunk relations okay and um I
said Vietnamese people are jungle age I
didn't really mean anything I wasn't
even trying to get a laugh you know I
mean it was just that's what I said and
then and I could see other Asian Comics
Now using the term just free nearly as
if they came up with it but anyway my
point is this is that then I then my
manager calls me she goes um yeah people
at Disney they're like some Asian kids
at Disney that work there that are just
infuriated that you said that so then I
had to go to like a Vietnamese News
[Laughter]
I meant by it is is that you know I mean
you know that's I know it's insulting
but we're all the same you know I mean I
was just trying to like your apology to
her I did an apology to her that was
back in the day I've had to apologize
for a lot of things but it's like yeah
but I've said crazy things so but you're
not offended by that no I'm I'm not but
I can see how other people can end it
because what if you know not all jungle
Asians if they are jungle agents live in
the jungle they live in the houses
that's right
Eskimo snow Asians I'm sure there are
some Eskimos that live in the desert
yeah I think it's just uh they don't I
don't think Inuits live in the desert I
know but I mean I know but if a Eskimo
moved to like Joshua tree is it like a
Hawaiian that moves to Vegas yeah it's
still a you know Hawaiian yeah well
that's kan's point exactly it's like not
everyone not everyone geographically
like Southeast Asian is gonna live in a
jungle could I just say this though
please defend but here's my defense all
right everything I've known about
Vietnamese people was through movies and
that fan and that fan yeah beef no I
love dad's fan what do you talk about I
have no idea what you're talking about
you're right you're right I [__] love
that guy that was movies yeah yeah
you're right right so Full Metal Jacket
apocalypse no platoon all of which were
filmed in the Philippines by the way
yeah jungle Asian I am a jungle Asian
yeah yeah and there's a lot of jungle
there yeah I mean there's more jungle
than non-jungle
yeah no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no because a lot of
like the northern part is very
mountainous kind of like I would say the
South you talk about the Vietnamese no
the Philippines okay that's true you
haven't been everywhere that's true okay
so I take but anyway but I didn't mean
anything bad about it right or you know
there wasn't any ill will toward but I
had to do the apology tour but there are
people like you that you're not offended
yes are you offended by like um racial
slurs no not really
it's because like I always think about
if someone is trying to offend me I
always think what's going on with them
that they have so much going on with me
man
there's so many issues you're right it's
on me dude I'm the one usually it's just
projecting and I don't feel like they're
trying I don't I don't feel like they're
trying to hurt me if I was a superhero
that'd be my name projector
constantly you're projecting my [__] to
the toward them yeah man yeah you're
right so I'm projecting right but um and
in retrospect maybe I shouldn't have
done the uh the apology to her but I
always ended up like I mean this was a
time when there was no social media it's
not like you could just turn the camera
on yourself and say hey I'm sorry this
was a time where you probably had your
manager probably had to call like a
Vietnamese publication and go find like
the local Vietnamese like Community like
no I think Mad TV had to do it okay
that's what I'm saying like so I was on
Mad TV and for some reason that makes it
funnier for me
yeah I think the TV show had had
resources like you know you have to you
know yeah but um but I also remember the
very first time I was on that it was
2000 I got on the show and there were I
remember being stay here I want you to
talk to you about
um I like you a lot I like you too
thank you it's a robot so
um in fact I want to see you more often
okay yeah
one more one more because I had to do
things in threes
um I have OCD but um but I remember like
there was a thing called Planet Mad TV
and it was a forum right and I remember
it was the Reddit back in the day back
in the day yeah and I I wasn't used to
like I've never read things about myself
ever in real time because back then it's
like if there was no such thing as the
internet I wouldn't I would think that I
was the king of the world
You're just showing up to work you know
what I mean and um and you're still on
the show and you're killing it but but
when I read There was literally pages
about how terrible I am oh on that thing
and I just remember being like I didn't
know anything about now I I don't even
read it and there are millions of forums
that like hate me but it's like I would
never read it but back then I just
remember being
just so like sad and depressed and like
you know I mean and worth I felt
worthless but now you know you you get
strengthened by that I don't know why I
got into that but um I don't know but I
don't think
why am I sitting here I don't think I
don't think any of that stuff should
matter anyway because it's not true
about you I don't think so man I can't
and you've heard the worst of the worst
things he said so that's a really yeah
yeah and Ken if you had a vagina oh my
gosh I can't say that you'll say it
anyway that's it
if you had a vagina that'd be cool
but Dick's good too yeah for sure
yeah I think I feel like I was going
into a [__] a gray a grayer yeah I
don't prefer I like a mouth I love both
sexes okay go back wow are you
are you real with yourself dig deep I
want you to look me in the eyes like